question s'adresse à Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire mise de l'économie monsieur le
ministre nous connaissons depuis
longtemps et nous partageons à une
époque la conviction commune qu'il
fallait lutter contre les déficits or
depuis 5 ans et demi que vous êtes mise
de l'économie vous serez le ministre du
record historique du déficit public du
déficit budgétaire mais aussi et voilà
l'exploit du déficit commercial
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues nous
pouvons penser que en fin d'année nous
serons à 200 milliards de déficit
commercial 150 milliards sur trois
trimestres et il s'aggravent de
trimestres en trimestre alors Monsieur
le Ministre comment analysez-vous votre
échec et quelle à partir de cette bonne
analyse quelle piste avez-vous pour
redresser la barre
[Applaudissements]